pas d'école pour les élèves de l'école
le Lorca à Vaulx-en-Velin aujourd'hui
pour ne pas risquer de se faire mordre
par un rat car oui l'école en est
infestée qui remonte en masse par les
canalisations des toilettes de l'école
qui circulent dans les couloirs grignote
les vêtements des élèves des excréments
ainsi que des cadavres de rats ont été
retrouvés ce qui dégage forcément une
odeur désagréable dans tous les
établissement voilà bien sûr Bourg-Blanc
c'est à côté de Lyon la mer de Lyon bien
sûr Anne Hidalgo
certainement responsable voilà de ce qui
se passe voilà c'est ça fait froid dans
le dos je vous dis non mais on en rigole
mais avouer que c'est chaud
qui a été attaquée en voulant faire fuir
le rat comme il a attaquer comment elle
a voulu faire il avait une équerre elle
a voulu le faire fuir parce que il y a
des excréments dans les salles de pause
donc les agents les instits ne peuvent
plus aller dans les salles de pause elle
a voulu fuir faire fuir le rat et il a
attaqué donc les parents ont payé les
morceaux il a sauté il a voulu
l'attaquer c'est des rats extrêmement
violents et agressif c'est vraiment la
panique je connais pas la le style de
rats très agressif et les parents à
l'air depuis la rentrée
depuis la rentrée donc là ils espèrent
dératiser ils avaient mis des appâts ça
n'a pas perdu ils vont dératisé ce
weekend normalement il paraît que les
rats sont de plus en plus intelligents
je vous dis et je vous le dis en ce soir
je ferai un grand prime sur les rats en
janvier je vous jure que c'est vrai
c'est pas une vanne on est en train de
travailler dessus voilà ça nourriture au
lit je vous jure que ça reste après la
grande race
je me suis pas une vague on va vraiment
vraiment en train de le travailler et ce
sera pas sur ces vidéos regardez alors
regardez alors ça voilà voilà alors
faut-il protéger les rats non les races
c'est compliqué parce que les rats ont
des qualités mais là c'est l'invasion
des rats c'est plus possible il y a des
millions d'euros partout il faut lutter
et dans votre prime peut-être que vous
trouverez des solutions parce qu'on en
peut plus il remonte dans Paris moi je
boulevard Sébastopol Jean-Marie
boulevard Sébastopol maintenant on est
accompagné de rat on marche le soir on
est accompagnés
si vous voulez voir le gars était comme
ça
si vous voulez voir des rats vous allez
au cinéma entre deux séances les rats
viennent bouffer les pop-corns qui sont
tombés il y en a des milliers tu dis
c'est pas possible il me courait entre
les gens c'est faux
j'étais toute seule sur la place du
Châtelet il était 3h du matin
j'attendais si j'étais
énormément j'étais rentré un soir
il avait des grosses couilles
[Applaudissements]
là c'est trop cher
allez allez
une injustice ça y est ça y est c'est
bon ça va c'est bon la barbe Daniel tu
nous parlais le rongeur
j'étais près de la bouche de métro la
bouche
c'est pour ça sans doute qu'il est passé
il est sorti de la bouche de métro il
est passé directement entre mes jambes
ce matin
toujours hein les rats et tout et c'est
vrai que vu que je n'habite pas à Paris
je n'ai jamais vu ces fameux rap
parisiens mais semaine dernière enfin
non cette semaine j'étais aux Halles et
pour la première fois il y a un rat
parisien effectivement qui me passe
tranquillou à côté de moi à 1 mètre et
non et ça m'a fait bizarre donc voilà
donc ça m'a fait bizarre je comprends un
peu plus la réalité des trucs je peux
rouler un truc qui a une régulation à
faire je peux juste vous dire un truc je
viens de prendre une grande décision
vous ferez pas partie du prime vous
anecdotes sont pourries à tous non mais
qui a une vraie anecdote avec un truc
qui lui est arrivé genre vraiment quoi
franchement non personne voyons pas oui
merci merci
[Rires]
et moi j'avais des potes au placard ils
étaient devenus copain avec un
intelligent
du fromage il venait vraiment le
chercher